if I'm a cult leader good for me I feel
like right yeah I hate how they're
always like oh this [ __ ] cult leader
you know or whoever you know or like
whoever it is Billy Graham or like Mike
Lindell or whoever these people are you
know like uh
who the guy that did the XFL you know
all that [ __ ] but it's like I mean
if I'm a co-leader I'm I'm [ __ ] let's
do it yeah what would you do for your
cold
what would you have them do or what do
they need what do you someone needs to
do like once they're in how do you
maintain your membership I think sex
mostly yeah
you're right on the same page as pretty
much everyone else I think I mean the
only only you get into a cold I feel
like
is probably for some kind of light sex
you know
I don't know we had a guy one time on
here who beat
what's that does he has like a disease
or something where you can't talk hmm uh
he had a stutter
and he
he was in
um he was in that xmv cult yeah XIV the
one that they busted the guy really yeah
and then we did what happened with his
stutter it went away they cured it
though
so did it come back after or no he
didn't have him when I saw him really
you know it could have flared up later I
don't know but he uh I just if there's
enough people around you [ __ ] dude it
can heal diseases I think
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one